[Music]
um so I'm Johanna I'm Alyssa I guess you
might have figured that part out but we
are developer advocates for G suite
which yes is a product with a platform
who knew that that's I thought that's
okay though because we're gonna make you
so excited that you're all gonna be like
I'm done listening to them I'm just
gonna open my computer and do some G
sweet magic right now right so you ready
you ready okay so we want to talk about
Auto magic in quarterly reports because
we all hate doing the things that our
managers asked us to do that keep us
from writing our code right man it's
tedious it's not hard it's just really
annoying sometimes because let's think
about it the last time that you had to
do some sort of summary monthly or
quarterly you probably went to your
inbox or two driving those like where
was the last quarters report and then
you opened it up made a copy change this
title changed a couple slides took that
to your meeting and then everyone called
you out when you kind of forgot to
update slide seven somebody had to do it
I really appreciate your attention to
detail
you're a great teammate yeah it's my 20%
project so it's approved yeah
that was really nice how you did that so
now I'm never gonna copy anything ever
again
but I still don't want to do the work
because every time I think about I'm
like oh my gosh it charred and a table
and numbers they're so hard chart title
that was harsh medias and annoying and I
don't want to do it okay
so how can we get around this I think
I'm sorry like asking you I think that's
all right oh I thought you were gonna
tell me shiitake mushrooms okay so oh
yeah I remember now there's two problems
we have to solve one we need fresh data
because last quarters data is just going
to get us in trouble
right I mean sometimes it's it's getting
Joanna in trouble I'm usually perfect so
it doesn't really
you're known are just always so mean to
me in meetings no it's fine it's fine I
love my teammates they're great I think
is after you've got your friend Sheena
you really want to wait to do the
tedious generating of the report part
for you and we're gonna show you how we
wrote that and you can just copy it if
you want it's on get out so we start oh
my god this is still running there's so
many charged yeah I mean these are
weekly first problem in fresh data we
need our dinner to be the freshest right
and like we all saw the keynotes in the
developer keynote in like four point
seven five seconds your post card photo
can go around the world is great so how
can we use Google to make sure that your
data is so fresh that nobody ever calls
you out again just because of slide set
I'm over it I promise I'm totally over
it I'm not upset at all okay well
there's this thing called the bigquery
data connector you might have heard of
this you probably also in our keynote
saw the preview of our connected sheets
initiative this is actually going to
make it a lot easier because you don't
have to spend any time you don't have to
spin up App Engine like you can get
access to any of your data on almost all
data like set platforms that are out
there through different connectors
bigquery was the first data connector we
ever built we announced it last year
which means this year you could use it
right and then we also have like there's
a Salesforce data connector the whole
connected sheets thing will be so cool
we turn it on for you so the idea is
that if you're using G suite already for
your company which I know you all are
because we're the best product ever and
please don't say otherwise if you don't
agree I will hurt my feelings but if you
have an enterprise or business G suite
account and you're running your business
off of it now you can actually make it
really really easy for anyone in your
company who needs access to data to
actually grab it when they need it
without needing to have any kind of
knowledge about what data even really is
and it's all because of a UI based
connector that we're really proud of but
we didn't build it so don't be proud of
us
okay that was the whole solution for a
problem one this is a product that
exists thanks to the engineering team
and we don't do anything for it so you
should all use it because it's really
really cool so the hard problem is all
that tedious work but I really
want to do do you want to do it yeah the
copy-paste do you want to do it
everybody you should do it do you ever
have those days I'll do it I don't work
who's this and you just feel like you're
like staring at your computer not doing
anything at all but everyone's like oh
man you're such a hard worker and you're
like yeah I am definitely didn't copy
and paste that from last time so we're
gonna solve those days that when you are
zoning out you can just play all the
solitaire you want like no-one's owning
out you know copy-paste that's zoning
out no errors to catch later on okay so
the way that this actually works is I've
already mentioned we're gonna talk about
sheets and obviously we're gonna use
slides for our presentation because G
suite is the best ever and has all the
things that you need and you never have
to go anywhere else
outside of your browser but the thing
that makes it all come together is what
we call AB script this is our magic
component one person knows what this is
oh my gosh I'm so excited you're like
the third I've met all week has anyone
here ever actually opened the script
editor for AB script oh my gosh that's
like just doubled my number for the week
I'm excited no like this is really great
okay so this is gonna run for like a
decade and now that you all know that I
dig this you're gonna be really really
excited about it because it's the
easiest thing ever and more importantly
than that it's the most magical thing
that ever existed it's basically a
unicorn rocket ceiling into this done
without burning up is pink yes it is
about what your dreams look like what is
your dream look like I'm sure it will me
are you dreaming because a unicorn
rocket that's bright pink sailing into
the Sun without burning up is basically
the coolest thing ever
just like AB script right okay so a
brief context on app script which is why
you're all gonna love it because the
thing I love about app script is that
it's written inside of your drive editor
it compiles and drive it runs from Drive
you can deploy it from Drive it has
triggers from Drive so basically if
you're a sweet you could do it in like
30 minutes and solve a problem that you
really hate having to do but if you're
not as sweet it's actually incredibly
approachable and you can get a lot done
with very little
coding experience so literally all of
you should love this do you love it okay
you will I'll come back to you please
okay so right here we have an example we
have five lines of code and in five
lines of code we're using three
different Google services to basically
pull an address out of a map find the
actual map of that location and email it
to a friend I'm friend and I'm gonna
fold on Milton because I'm still a
little sore with you wait have you seen
that lately
I haven't and he's actually the one that
usually gets us the day yeah like she's
he's the one we get all their data from
if you all see Milton let me know we're
gonna go get Garrett out so five lines
of code three services and it actually
really is this simple there's no setup
there's no libraries to thing there's no
plugins to install like there's a whole
my gosh you never have to go back to
maven again if you don't want to you
could just join my AB script closer
forever wouldn't that be great yeah
would ya would so it's really really
simple spreadsheet app that gets you to
the spreadsheet you can get the current
sheet you can get a sheet by an ID or a
sheet by your name you can search
through your drive this is just the
magic world and then we expand to other
Google services such as Maps and these
are called our advanced services and if
you'd like to know more go to
developers.google.com/jobs script and
how great and easy it is and you totally
believe me you have no questions
whatsoever
Alysha is gonna give a demo and this is
the best demo ever because it was
written by our friend and cork or Anu
and she's the best she um
so again don't be proud of us cuz we
didn't do this except Alicia made it
better so she did a little bit of work
but don't be proud of me alright so this
is a real example of a presentation we
gave Acme corporation recently
definitely went there and we definitely
gave this presentation we're finding
that we're having to make this
presentation for all of our customers
but here's what it looks like we start
out logo talk about the team who's the
sales team what opportunities do we have
we have a pie chart their business
revenue what are our top closes how many
widgets have we sold
how many widgets are we about to sell
how many widgets need attempt yeah we're
so professional in business like we've
got this down this is slide 7 I just
thought I'd point that up so we found
out that this is kind of following the
same template and actually if any of you
have done mail merge you might see we
kind of merge this into a slides
template so we were using some curly
brackets here just it's kind of whatever
you want to use you could use those are
you layering with a rock important to
have Flair and we like curly or Flair so
we kind of went through this deck and we
took each of our fields and and added
curly brackets and you can see here we
have a really nice template of what that
slide deck looks like so just like mail
merge we're gonna be able to take our
data and just kind of merge it into this
slide deck you can already imagine that
right but we talked about getting the
data that fresh data so I'm going to go
into my spreadsheet I'm gonna show you
this is the data connector so this is
connected out to our bigquery
opportunities table and I'm actually
pulling in a specific query here I'll
show you the query it's really simple
this is you about where my sequel this
is what your careers all look like right
they're all so simple so I'm select
starring everything from this table I've
created a where where class for my
account in my region cuz I do these
slides X for a specific company in a
specific region and I can just actually
tie those parameters to a different tab
or field reference in my spreadsheet so
I'll show you where I have that I'm kind
of setting up this like hey if Alisa
didn't show up next week how could we
create this slide Zac well I definitely
can't be trust you just have to click
that account name that you want like our
unicorn rocketship Yampa knew that we we
like to work with and I'm from the
Midwest so I can go over here to my
table click refresh and it will take
those parameters in go out to the query
and pull my data back in so now that I
have my data I need to somehow get it
into my slide deck that's actually where
that app script comes in so
is the code editor that I can access
directly from my spreadsheet and I have
some code here and this code does a
couple things the first thing it does is
it takes that template slide deck and it
makes a copy and it just renames it for
us and then down here let's see we
create our intro slides so we take our
CR curly brackets so we're gonna replace
our account name with the actual account
name region with the actual region see
it gets a little bit more interesting
down here we're actually gonna make a
chart so you leave absolute so add
actually a temporary tab we're gonna
make a chart and then we're gonna copy
and paste that chart into our slide deck
and then we're gonna clean up our work
because that's what good programmers do
and then down here we actually to get
kind of our top top closes we're near
closes we actually just do a little bit
of sorting on those values in the
spreadsheet and then replace that text
in the slide so now that I have my code
ready to kind of take all of that data
and merge it in I have a little button
over here that just kicks off that slide
deck so I'll hit generate this button is
tied to my app script so anyone in the
sheet can create their own report so
while it's running it's going to start
running my script and at some point
we're gonna see this really cool tab
come up it's like a dance party time
like slide deck
this is gonna be copied and pasted and
then completely destroyed but don't
worry it's in the slide deck and then we
can see in our drive that it has just
created this new slide deck I bet slide
sad what has got here at this time all
over I mean we'll see just make one look
at it looking pretty accurate yeah yeah
I'll have to talk to Diane about that
yeah so I think that's about it now I
think I've just taken something that
probably takes me I don't know like an
hour to eight hours a day depending on
how like much your focus I mean
depending on how much you're staring at
your
Green so I think I'm gonna just like
head on down to tchotchkes now okay but
I don't even have it before you go okay
we're like maybe show them how you got
to some of this stuff oh good a
spreadsheet why don't you open the
bigquery data yeah like how would you
started if you want to get started with
that you can just go to the data menu
data connectors and bigquery and then it
brings up a new you select your billing
project and it'll create a new tab where
you can have multiple tabs within one
spreadsheet that pull from different
tables if you'd like different ways to
bring queries and that is it that's the
whole fresh data problem solved and I
feel like that's like some props for our
engineering teams that aren't here we
didn't invite them because that's not
their job this is our job but we're very
bit out of yarns so like everyone be
like really happy of our engineering
teams like Thanks oh thank you I'll be
sure to tell them that you clap for them
wait can you go back to the demo box
oh yeah um or I want to see how do I get
to Apps Script yeah let's go to the Apps
Script out yeah how would you open it so
just from the Tools menu you can go to
script editor and that will open up this
tab here and now there's a really cool
thing about Apps Script which is from
any Google document whether it's
actually a doc or a sheet or slide you
can always open from the inside the
document and that Apps Script will be
bound to that document so if you share
that with somebody else they can
actually edit the script if they need to
and they can run it it makes it really
easy but if you ever wanted to make a
script that's separate from any existing
document how would you do that
script.google.com grep Google com
it's really easy I hope you can remember
it but if you can't once again its
script stuff google calm so we see it
like four more time you should just
tweet at us and then we can tweet back
yeah we could tell you if you ask us on
Twitter but also at script a little calm
you can see all of your scripts that you
have written and with the execution
nation on their executions and whether
or not they're still going on every
night at 2:00 in the morning to update
your calendar for you because
like bad at that and then one other
thing I want to talk about can we go
back to the spreadsheet yeah and to the
tab that you wrote the generator tab oh
yeah okay so I'm gonna guess that not
everyone you work with at work is like
as clever as you all are right like
that's a thing it's very frustrating
sometimes but you don't have to waste
any more time explaining to them how
your code works you can just like trust
me it works I tested it there's
definitely unit tests it's definitely
never gonna fail and instead you can
make an interactive way for them to use
an app script so that you don't have to
keep sending the same email every month
and it saves your dates and they don't
even have to go into the editor so this
is something that I could do it makes it
really easy for me to make the report
but it's really great when I go out of
town or I want to transition that report
to somebody else once you get slides
look at it's a mountain I shouldn't get
rusted but Alysha actually made this
because of her experience like having to
live her entire life in spreadsheets and
knowing how incredibly tedious it can be
to even remember what you yourself did
nevermind what somebody else did and
there's some one of my favorite plugs
for AB script which is make it easy for
everyone else that you interact with and
it'll still be easy for you alright so
that's a pretty cool demo yeah let's go
back oh I guess our demos over by magic
people so a couple of gotchas once again
bigquery data connectors for business
and enterprise G suite accounts if you
have a gmail account you might not
actually want to try this maybe just
don't do that because otherwise you'll
be sad but I don't want you to be sad I
want you to be happy people with your
business and enterprise G suite accounts
the other thing is that data access is
important in order to use an app script
or in order to use the bigquery data
connector you do need to have access to
that original document or to that data
set and if you don't this can make it
kind of tricky to run our specific demo
that's definitely available online and
we even have only to prove that one so
you can trust me on this phrase because
sometimes I'm a liar but if you don't
have access it's not the end of the
world because AB script is super duper
magic oh we should have copied our
unicorn over to the next slide so I
could emphasize how awesome a super cool
unicorn rocket that flies into the Sun
without
up in his bright pink is do you believe
you know apps for ports on any account
it works on any account it doesn't have
a holiday so it can be a gmail account
you can make them for yourself you can
make them for your company you can do a
domain wide installation you can sell
them as an add-on in the marketplace
like they are full magic and full
awesome and very very easy to make we
have one on our team that everyone has
stolen that our TL made that literally
just crops a spreadsheet to the cells
that you're using you don't have a
thousand roll rows by accident love that
thing but the other thing is a script
can still solve problems maybe you don't
have access to the data set that you
need to include in your analysis for
some reason like it's some other team
but it's relevant to your entire
initiative but if you get a monthly
update email from them you could write
an app script to look for that email
copy the information over and then
include it in your work automatically
without ever having to read the email
because it could still be filtered we
all love our filters and if you don't
know how your filters work you should
talk to me in about three minutes and
eleven ten nine seconds so it basically
never ends and then there's a lot more
things that actually can help like if
you haven't started with Apps Script yet
and you're terrified of JavaScript that
dates back to like the 1990s or
something like that that's okay too
because last year we released the macro
recorder for Google sheets and what the
macro recorder does is it records every
click that you make inside of your sheet
so that you can color everything once
make a new tab and then run it again and
not have to go through all of those 78
clicks every single time you have a new
tab and this is a great thing well
what's really cool is you can edit the
macros that were made for you and if you
do that you'll actually get a fully
written app script a very tedious
robotically written code but it can show
you how things work so if you're having
some trouble with a1 notation record
what you're trying to do as a macro look
at it and then steal from the computer
yeah this is how engineering works and
everyone's always intimidated you're
like y'all all we do is go to stack
overflow and then steal things that are
already written you can even macro
record refreshing the data from the data
connect so last night yeah but we forgot
to include it don't want to do it here
cuz I like the dramatic effect of like
refreshing yeah the button and to feel
like you did something you know
otherwise you really didn't do anything
and also we wanted to make sure it was
accurate last night and then we didn't
really want to do anything this morning
cuz we were tired and honest to remove I
really want to go home already but I'm
having so much fun with you all so I'm
not gonna go home early umm so not a
check-in are you in love with Apps
Script is there anything about it that
you're like nah hard pass that's what I
thought that I've got no hard passes the
whole world loves that you're all
convinced we've converted everyone a
dream that ever existed I'm excited and
that is how you can Auto magic your
quarterly reports and never have to do
them again while your boss still thinks
you're working really really hard maybe
you don't show them this YouTube video
but show your friends because you have
personality makes a lot more sense on
YouTube than it does in real life if you
have any questions tweet us we actually
answer with some fairly quick response
times we will answer eventually and then
check out the blog post that Ellucian a
new wrote copy their code steal it use
it for your own purposes we don't care
and then go to our developers side
google.com page because our tech writers
are the best tech writers in the whole
world and they're ours and they're the
best and they work really hard yeah
anything else I think that's how I got
started with Apps Script is all you guys
got it like a year ago yeah so we're
gonna go to chotchkie's
y'all stay here have fun go right in
bye thanks for coming
[Applause]
[Music]